I believe that the word cold cases is
wrong because it could be perhaps
something that's in a drawer somewhere
in an office but their family's hasn't
forgotten them and they're still looking
for them and I just want to do my best
to help
when authorities have failed to identify
the remains of a body there is very
little hope of closure for these john
and jane doe's but every year an
enterprising studio of student artists
used their knowledge of the human form
to try and breathe life into these cold
cases here we're doing a forensic
reconstruction of a real case trying to
get it as close as he used to look like
when he was alive so we can identify him
we are given a 3d print not the real
skull we use it as a framework so we can
reconstruct the anatomy of the
individual first we start adding the
muscles on the framework given by the
bone and then we try to complete those
things that are not so clear like the
ear or the mouth right now I'm working
on Caucasian white man between 40 to 60
years old there are indications that he
lost his teeth when he was alive and his
bones are telling me all that these
lifelike models are provided to
authorities often reinvigorating
investigations and bringing much-needed
closure to loved ones after my first
experience last year I was lucky enough
that the person was identified and I got
this beautiful letter from the family
members saying thank you
when we see this process it feels almost
like you're resuscitating someone but I
know that beyond that where your
resuscitating is the life of those
families that are looking for this
person